hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu
and today we're getting all up in our
fields which is pretty common with this
show but this time it's not
me getting into my feels but the
characters and that's nice isn't it
let's discuss episodes 122
and 123 122 and finally we get to see
what the king and otero
are up to there's a lot of posturing
going on and a lot of narrowed eyes from
the tarot but i also think that natero
has knuckles energy here having seen
mary looking after his girlfriend
there's less desire to kill him which
makes sense what he is doing or noting
though is that mary is fighting to
combine his ant
and human forms now i don't mind that
natera's behavior is like knuckles which
might seem hypocritical but it
is not and here's why ready natero
thought it through and came up with a
plan
natero took the time to assess the
situation and follow through
i don't know but i think natero also
knows he ain't gonna survive this
especially after his first attack
only smacked out a nosebleed that is how
he is not like
knuckle that is why i'm okay with this i
feel like we've come
a long way with tarot since his ogling
of boobies back in the first arc he's
obviously the leader and well thought of
for a reason
i'm not sure yet what all the hunters
will take the blame business is they'll
take the blame for saving the planet or
for killing a restricted creature i
don't know i'm not actually sure i feel
like i've missed something along the way
or it hasn't been explained clearly
enough natera is a good guy
playful boob-loving and needs to learn
to look at eyes occasionally but
generally well thought of and
careful that he's wearing his special
shirt special shorts and special
hair special socks he went to combat in
his special socks that he's wearing his
special socks tell us either that he
definitely
is here to kill or that he wants to die
in his favorite outfit and i can respect
that you know what he's noticing is
something that's been becoming clear to
pretty much everyone at this point
mary's conflicted mary's unsure if he's
an ant or a man and while he's trying so
hard to be a man
the ant comes through which is how
natera sees it except i'm not sure i do
i sort of see things the other way and
i'm not sure whether i'm right on this
but i feel as though the ant is the
better and the human the worst generally
we assume the internal conflict is ant
equals evil and human equals good but
there are so many
problematic humans in this world and
they so often have
nen abilities by comparison we see all
these ants using their men for good and
just to exist whether they're good comes
from being an ant or from being human
i'm really not sure but i think natera's
assumption that it's the human
who wants to be good is sort of
misplaced or at the very least i think
what natero's simplifying is a very
complex issue ultimately testing the
king's resolve by
challenging him to a duel without death
is a fascinating way to do things
getting kicked in the gooch for your
troubles is equally fantastic
ultimately there is no way for natera to
understand or trust that the king's
personality will
stay the same once he's settled i think
there's a lot of respect on both sides
and that's going to make this fight all
the more interesting to watch because if
poof finds them thus engaged in pitched
battle
that doesn't look intentionally fatal
that traitorous heart of poofs is going
to
spring out once more more so if mary's
offering naterro a place by his side
jigglypuff is a very complex yet utterly
simple character
and i would argue one of the more
devious specifically defined characters
they all have their goals and follow
them through but few of the characters
are so laser focused on exactly what
they want that they'll betray every ally
to get there poof doesn't seem to find
it fun
he doesn't do it for cruelty's sake or
seemingly revenge or anything like that
he does it because he has uncompromising
values and just grimly gets to work
his thought processes are great and
it'll be interesting to see which of the
locations he decides to commit his body
to
the king or kamugi which will best serve
his needs or match his values
he's now heading to the best strategic
position of all he'll have
all the information and the ability to
do exactly what he needs to
ultimately i think it's going to depend
on how he perceives the king is treating
the human
and whether getting his name solidifies
the ant or the human side
shifting briefly to gon and pito knowing
the entire story of what happened has
changed gone
in some way does he still have the same
undying hatred
i'm not sure if the hatred is a strong
now his eyes softened and in fairness
he's going to get what he wants in
theory the most luck-filled thing of the
episode was pito not explaining how the
king was carrying kamugi if jigglypuff
had found that out it would have
complicated
all sorts of things but they didn't
describe it because they didn't know how
which tells you everything about how
pito wants a caring
softer king but doesn't really know what
that actually means it's quite beautiful
frankly though heartbreaking when you
consider how many ants remember their
former lives
there's something pitiful about pito
wanting softness while being unable to
identify it and i hope we get to see
more of that
now on to the episode the episode one
the one that is after this one this
episode was a very odd one but i suppose
quite timely and that it confuses
exactly what i started to question
after watching the previous episode
which is the idea that we don't know
whether it's the ants or the humans that
are the monsters is an ongoing crisis
for me and
seeing well finn soften like that was an
unexpectedly pleasant situation
especially after seeing and experiencing
icalgo having that inner turmoil of not
being able to be the monster he thinks
he should be or the monster he expects
to be which makes me wonder whether he
thinks he should be able to kill without
fear
and whether he thinks torture is a
better outcome or a better thing to do
like i don't know torture versus killing
torture's pretty bad there are things
worse than death you know
i find it interesting that as soon as
he's in enough pain he's absolutely fine
to torture or hurt others and i wonder
what that says to the metaphor of ant
versus human
especially since in his mind it's about
protecting his friends and assuming he's
going to die
since he didn't know the conditions on
wolfboy's abilities it was such a quick
turnaround on the frankly
disgusting centipede situation i
gagged at that the quick turnaround on
the on the centipede situation to what a
great flaw to have built into an ability
the idea that the truth telling went so
deep and that the need to get answers
from one or the other was the key to
unlocking and removing them
is a beautiful outcome ikalgo being
willing to sacrifice himself to the
cause his friends have put themselves to
is a powerful one and it was in the
learning of that that i wonder whether
he will kill now
whether he's been changed by that
potential disabling rather than killing
is a very specifically different
behavior and i do wonder how it's going
to be used from this point on
particularly given he's about to find
palm only to learn that she's somehow
been
antified by who exactly she's the newest
member of the next generation of ants so
i wonder who she'll have allegiance
toward or if she'll be the new queen ant
maybe the central eye or gem or whatever
it is in the middle of her face suggests
to me that she might be a queen
just because of the previous queen but
it could also be used to hark back to
the gem she used to be able to see into
to see whoever she has seen before so
many scenes
when she's ready she and the tiny baby
are going to be odd additions to the ant
farm back to wolf boy though there's so
much to be said about his art he's
always wanted to be the king behind the
scenes and now it makes sense
he couldn't be the king even in life but
he wanted to be close to the center of
power because he was weak there's a
sadness in that that's hard to place and
tagashi has an interesting way of making
sure we know
about the traumatic characters lives so
many of them have experienced trauma but
it seems
so specifically targeted toward the evil
or bad characters that it's as though
we're supposed to forgive them for being
the way they are maybe forgetting that
we
also have characters like kilwa who's
the sweetest little murder boy
it's a slippery slope i think for giving
people simply because they experience
something traumatic and while we want to
take things like that into account
softening the view which is exactly what
i've done and i will do
again because i'm human it allows space
for people to be cruel as long as they
can back it up with a traumatic
narrative
it's the whole your trauma isn't invalid
but the behaviors you enact as a result
are also not a good thing and you
probably should not be engaging in that
except when i think about it what has
wolfboy done this entire time sure he's
had bad intentions and he's lied to
people but it's all been in fear and
paranoia none of it's actually amounted
to
almost literally anything we've been
following him around for ages and i'm
still trying to figure out what he's
done that has changed the story in any
way
he hasn't that i recall done anything so
i sort of feel
bad now then again if he could have
would he have done something bad or did
he just
want to be the right hand hound of
someone else
did he just miss being with his friend
his friend gyro who the king resembles
apparently
unless i didn't understand that right
and let's be honest i might not have
if the king does resemble gyro it
confirms my belief that he is
gyro and it brings into play the idea
that welfin really didn't want to hurt
his king
being the king behind the scenes never
meant actually try to usurp just
keep an eye on everything and actually
maintain loyalty and what's he going to
do now just
lay still until the situation's done
having opened up to octobuddy will he
remain openly friendly with octobuddy
can we just appreciate for a moment how
beautiful it is that ikalgo's
determination to stay true to his
friends and his willingness to die for
them and
his desire to show care for them was so
powerful that the magic of friendship
may have saved his life let's just
appreciate that because kiwa made that
happen
gone retrieved his friend from his home
kilwa traveled with him kiwa was saved
by someone else and deemed that someone
a friend
while he calgo hasn't decided that
wolfboy is a friend he has essentially
turned welfan into an ally by being who
he is he has
unlocked truthfulness truthfulness isn't
a i mean it's a word
unlocked honesty it turns out that maybe
being
unwilling to kill has actually been his
greatest strength rather than greatest
flaw and
gee i'm glad because we need some
wholesome crying in amongst all the
speculation on humanity right
speaking of wholesome let's wholly
finish this up because that's it from me
if you enjoyed this philosophical
querying of humanity
and manatee and existence click here
here and here don't forget to like share
subscribe hit
bells and i'll see you next time
get a sound